wie finden sie eigentlich Robert Habeck
persönlich nach wie vor ausgesprochen
aber steht dann sehr großes aber im Raum
nicht aber ich glaube momentan finde ich
nicht dass seine vernünftige Politik
macht aber das wird er anders sehen
insofern ist auch der Grund warum ich
den gleichen Parteien sind seit wann ist
das so sie sie haben immer sehr gelobt
sie haben gesagt das ist ein richtig
guter Mann auch hier in der Sendung ich
habe sie mal wir haben das mal
rausgeholt sehr interessant vor ein paar
Jahren mal haben wir sie nach Robert
habe gefragt ich glaube 2017
na da kann sie reinhören die Kamera aus
dem Schwärmen nicht oh Gott ich möchte
sagen es war kurz vor Liebe bitte
[Gelächter]
setzt die beiden großen Parteien haben
wir begriffen dass die große Koalition
wirklich auf dem Land Gelegenheit dass
ich da was ändern muss und es wird
spannend zu sehen wie das am 24
September ausgeht ja grün haben sich
bedauerlicherweise falsch entschieden
Kandidaten
Schleswig-Holstein mit dem sie gerade
Jamaika machen ja toller Typ wie ich
finde schade als Liberale aber trotzdem
der wäre auch gewesen für viele Menschen
die sagen immer zwischen uns
zu wählen mit mir und ja
sage ich doch kurz vor Liebe das ist
dann passiert na gut zunächst einmal
haben wir ich finde wirklich sehr
problemlos orientiert an der
Jamaika-Koalition Schleswig-Holstein
gespiegelt die wäre es jetzt ohne uns
beiden ja gar nicht gegeben allerdings
Gegner und wir beide haben auch 2017
miteinander gerungen darum eine Jamaika
Christopher Bundesebene zu zu
hinzubekommen die aus viel Gründen dann
nicht funktioniert hat und wir haben
auch gemeinsam noch für eine Ampel 2021
uns vereinbart ich will jetzt nicht
spekulieren über das was mit ihm
passiert ist nach wie vor ein toller
Mensch und ein pragmatischer Typ aber er
hat eine ganze Reihe keine Ahnung was
wollen sie sagen eine ganze Reihe von
Problemen die viel damit zu tun haben
dass er nicht der Herrscher bei Bündnis
90 die Grünen ist was ganz vorsichtig er
muss immer Rücksicht nehmen was in
Schleswig-Holstein nie musste
auf Strömungen seiner Partei die er
möglicherweise noch braucht für seine
weiteren Ambitionen und das hemmt ihn
etwas finden was heißt das Reden sie mal
klar und deutlicher
diplomatisch reden
ich glaube dass er das Gefühl hat dass
er sehr schnell beweisen muss dass er
ein guter Wirtschaft Energieminister ist
und deshalb viele Dinge in einer
Geschwindigkeit auf dem Weg bringen die
für die Problemlösung nicht gerade nicht
gerade zielführend sind er befindet sich
in einem internen Wettbewerb nach wie
vor mit einer Lena Berber persönlich
mental aber auch faktisch um die Frage
wenn die Grünen noch mal kannst du
stellen sollten warum diesmal nicht er
sondern sie und deshalb muss er was hat
er gelernt früher war ganz anders früher
war mehr so wie ich gesagt völlig
wurscht wir machen das einfach jetzt hat
er gelernt er muss auf Ströme und
Rücksicht nehmen die im Frühjahr egal
gewesen wäre ich behaupte das kann ja
morgen präsentieren wenn es nur nach
Robert habe gegangen wäre hätten wir die
Kernkraftwerke auch noch mindestens bis
Ende 24 weiterlaufen lassen und dann
hätten wir sie abgeschaltet aus
Sicherheitsgründen nicht weil wir eher
und ich Fans von Kernkraftwerken sind
sondern auch aus Sicherheitsgründen weil
die Sicherheitslage bei
Energieversorgung eben nicht so
optimistisch dargestellt werden kann wie
es gegenwärtig der Fall ist okay und
welche Rolle spielen sie dabei also wenn
ich Frau Künstler richtig verstanden
habe würde ich sagen sie sind sozusagen
der der Don Krawallo der dann regelmäßig
gegen habe austeilt ich teile deutlich
weniger gegen habe ich ausgegangen
andere aber richtig einmal mein Gott
miserable Politik was ihm alles
vorgeworfen haben
wirklich geil
[Gelächter]
können sie lösen die nehmen Sie das war
was passiert da gerade innerhalb dieser
Koalition es ist doch wirklich
interessant
man hat das Gefühl also man fragt sich
regelmäßig ich ist die FDP eigentlich
noch in dieser Regierung oder die
Opposition oder die bessere Opposition
jemand fragt sich ob sie jemals in
dieser Regierung angekommen ist oder ob
sie eigentlich immer noch mit der CDU um
den besten oppositionsplatz ist das ist
der Eindruck der sich mir eher
vermittelt wenn wir dieses ganz konkrete
Beispiel um über das wir wahrscheinlich
gleich noch reden werden
das stand im Koalitionsvertrag das ist
da drin dass wir werden um einbauen
er steht drin dass wir die Wärme wenn
wir wollen hin zu einer CO2 neutralen
Wärmeversorgung der steht nicht drin als
in den Wärmepumpe
diesem Koalitionsvertrag da steht sehr
viel drin da steht beispielsweise zur
entscheidende Satz wie lautet der haben
Sie denn im Kopf verhandelt sie sind
juristisch alles im Kopf aber ich kann
Ihnen sagen dass dort drin steht dass
wir die wärmewende wollen zur
CO2-neutralen Wärmeversorgung
klimaneutralen Wärmeversorgung möglichst
nicht unbedingt sondern möglichst und da
steht kein Wort von nur Wärmepumpe da
steht kein Wort von nur elektrisch was
ja auch unsinnig ist dazu kommen
vielleicht ne und darüber werden wir
noch im Deutschen Bundestag befinden wir
sind übrigens noch gar nicht so weit
Frau Prinzessin ich weiß dass die Zeit
das nicht weiß aber wir haben vielleicht
können Sie mir das vorwerfen
den Deutschen Bundestag sogar eingesetzt
worden
das ist interessant sondern es ist
Faktum wie funktioniert Gesetzgebung
vielleicht darf ich das mal ganz kurz
erklären
die Bundesregierung macht ein
Gesetzentwurf und leidet diesen den
Bundesrat zu das ist passiert der
Bundesrat hat dazu eine Stellungnahme
die geht zurück an die Bundesregierung
dann kann die Bundesregierung
Ausstellung damit machen und dann leitet
die Bundesregierung das im Deutschen
Bundestag das wird frühestens wenn
überhaupt nächste Woche passieren
momentan ist das Parlament mit der Frage
noch gar nicht beschäftigt auch wenn sie
denn dann schon 100 Fragen formuliert
wenn Sie das Ding noch gar nicht haben
wir sind ja also wir haben einen Wurzeln
was gar keine gute Frage sehr gute Frage
wir sind mit den Grünen in einer
Qualität ist noch nicht 100 Fragen wir
kennen den
Gesetzentwurf eine Reihe von Fragen das
ist einer Koalition so üblich eigentlich
in der Koalition noch üblich dass es
keine Gesetzentwürfe gibt die nicht
vorher besprochen worden sind neue
Methode entwickelt bei Windows 90 die
Grünen das passiert einfach so egal
jetzt haben wir eine Frage an das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium war vieles
von dem was dort drin steht behauptet
wird zutreffend ist und diese Frage
diese Fragen möchten beantwortet werden
müssen beispielsweise beispielsweise ob
es rechtlich überhaupt zulässig ist zu
differenzieren zwischen öffentlichen
Bauten und privaten Bauten ich halte das
für unzulässig dass man wenn es ja darum
geht CO2 einzusparen Ausnahmen für
öffentliche Bauten können also der Staat
darf von den von den Privaten nichts
verlangen was er nicht selbst zu geben
bereit es geht ja um CO2 Einsparungen
was anderes es geht um die Frage ob die
Berechnung der Kosten so zutreffend ist
da haben wir ganz große Zweifel ob die
mit ihrem 130 Milliarden Euro auskommen
es gibt mittlerweile Schätzungen die in
dem Billionen Bereich hineingehen es
gibt eine ganze Reihe von Fragen die
beantwortet werden müssen
sinnvollerweise okay wenn wir sie haben
diese Antworten auf diese Fragen
möglicherweise ändert sich das Gesetz ja
auch noch der Gesetzentwurf dann haben
wir eine Möglichkeit bei den Beratungen
in den Ausschüssen des Deutschen
Bundestages reagieren
sofort aber nur eine ganz große
Nachfrage damit verstehen weil sie
gerade und so schön das erklärt haben
wie das läuft also die Bundesregierung
macht dieses Gesetz
genau so nein also den Vorschlag meine
ich jetzt macht das Kabinett so dann
geht es in den Bundesrat sagt sie gerade
dann machen die Anmerkungen ja die haben
gerade im Bundesrat zusammen
mit vielen Anmerkungen bedauerlicher
sind wieder nicht Bundesrat also da sind
sie gar nicht beteiligt haben die nichts
mehr zu tun doch wir sind in zwei
Landesregierung glaube ich vertreten
aber der bundesratsentscheidung das was
momentan aber sie wissen was drin steht
das hilft ja nicht weiter also wie sie
sie die deutsche Öffentlichkeit weiß
auch nicht geworden ist dann geht das
wieder zurück ins Kabinett sagten sie
nachdem und dann wird irgendwann
vorgelegt ja dann kommst du in
Deutschland so dann kommst du in
deutschen Bundestag und noch bevor das
Ding überhaupt wirklich öffentlich ist
haben sie aber öffentlich und das ist
schon 100 Fragen das Ding ist doch
öffentlich dass du verschickt worden die
Verbände an die Presse welche Nummer man
daraus in der Öffentlichkeit medial
macht
ja wir haben erstmal nur Fragen
übermittelt
all diese Fragen längst stellen können
über die Tisch im Bundesrat
ich sitze nicht im Kabinett nein aber 92
Bundestag
sitzt in im Kabinett Frau stark
Watzinger sitzt im Kabinett und einige
andere auch
der Gesetzgeber ist der Deutsche
Bundestag sind scheiden die Fraktion des
Deutschen Bundestages nach Erörterung
vorher nicht dann
sagen wie viele Fragen zu Autobahnen
Neubau zu Haushalt zu
Kindergrundsicherung musste Christian
Lindner jetzt schon auf Drängen der
Grünen öffentlich beantworten Frage
die wenn das bmwk muss die Frage nicht
öffentlich beantworten wir erwarten
Zuleitung an die Fraktion des Deutschen
Bundestag haben sie irgendwas davon
Fragen Fragen
sowohl bei der Kindergrundsicherung
von Frau Pause vor allem bei Wissen bei
den Autobahn kann ich ihn sicher sagen
ganz Dutzende von Anfragen von Fragen
die Bündnis 90 und beantwortet haben
wollen aber nicht öffentlich es gibt
nicht dieses ganze diesen ganzen
öffentlichen Boden Zauber das ist das
World wenn sie sagen
wirklich nicht zielführend weil warum
wir haben als Bundestagsfraktion Fragen
gestellt das ist das normale
parlamentarische Verfahren die andere
Fraktion das auch machen wir haben diese
Fragen gestellt und wir erwarten von
keine Antwort in der eigenen Regierung
ja so macht man das normalerweise also
ich schicke jeden jeden zweiten Tag
schreiben an Ministerium und habe Fragen
interessant finde ist dass Herr Guppy
sich tatsächlich so generiert als sei er
Opposition dieses Gesetz jetzt mal ganz
unabhängig davon dass es einen langen
Koalitionsausschuss bei 30 Stunden gab
der sich geeinigt hat dass man es jetzt
macht lassen Sie mich kurz Ausreden das
ist ein ähm dass dieses Gesetz in den
sogenannten ressort-umlauf geht also
bevor das Wirtschaftsministerium das
als Kabinett gibt geht das durch alle
anderen Ministerien da hätte also die
FDP die Teil dieser Regierung ist
vielleicht nicht sicher aber ihre
Parteikollegen und andere hätten sein
können an diesem Punkt und diesen Mann
diesen Mann diesen best besser wird
besser noch mal nach wir könnten das
sogar stoppen sie können sagen in dieser
Ressort rumlaufen in diesem Motorrad wir
wollen das noch nicht dass sie noch
nicht fertig ist nicht passiert dann ist
es im Kabinett gewesen und es ist
verabschiedet also ist nicht
verabschiedet ist im Kabinett und geht
jetzt dann in den Bundestag und jetzt
sagen Sie in der nächsten Runde obwohl
sie Teil dieser Regierung sind
wir doch noch mal 100 Fragen das ist vom
habituellen ist es einfach Opposition
und nicht Teil einer
verantwortungsbewussten Bundesregierung
die früh versucht etwas
Vernünftiges Gesetz unabhängig davon was
die Zeit davon hält oder nicht ich bin
da mal sagen im Kabinett der erste der
erste Entwurf von Robert habe ging
zunächst raus an die an Verbände und
andere bevor überhaupt jemand befasst
worden ist dann kam der erste Entwurf
ins Kabinett da die FDP gesagt geht so
nicht zurück in die montage-halle dann
ist das zurückgegangen auch
interessanter Terminus ne das nicht von
mir aber trotzdem gut also noch mal gut
war wirklich gut ich finde den Begriff
ganz gut
zurück in die Montagehalle dieses Gesetz
ist so schlecht das muss Grund erneuert
werden
wir schon wieder bei Semantik
wir schicken das zurück und erwarten
Überarbeitung bitte also
ich streite mich immer total gerne mit
Ihnen und wir sollten uns jetzt mal
machen also wenn sie sagen das ist
Semantik einfach nur Wortklauberei dann
frage ich Sie warum machen Sie dann
diese Wortklauberei nicht Sie persönlich
aber in dem Fall die FDP sie machen doch
die Wortklauberei nehmen Sie solche
Vokabeln benutzen wir wissen doch ganz
genau dass es in der nächsten halben
Sekunde medial verfängt und dann rauf
und runter geht und das hat dann
irrsinniges Verhältnis Potenzial sein
und jetzt und jetzt sind wir bei dem
Punkt dass wir sagen jetzt müssen wir
dem zustimmen weil wir semantisch auf
der falschen Spuren aber sie werfen mir
sehr romantische Spielchen vorher
ich habe eine Begriff nicht gebraucht
ich habe gesagt ich finde gut hätte auch
von mir sein können aber
ich hatte nicht gebraucht ich habe nur
gesagt der Gesetzentwurf ist
zurückgegeben worden zu Überarbeitung
verstanden
Advokatur Semantik streichen ist es
glaube ich alt aus diskutiert was mich
umtreibt ist auch schlimm ne das weiße
harte Beleidigung
keine Politikerin sie darf das natürlich
also wenn man ich habe heute gelesen es
gibt 80% rund 80 % der Deutschen haben
laut Umfrage
Verunsicherung angesichts dieser Wärme
werden und das sind ja Leute ganz
unterschiedlicher Herkunft insbesondere
in Ostdeutschland wo Leute ein
Familienhäuser haben kleine
Einfamilienhäuser aber kein Geld und
jetzt hören die irgendwie 20.000 € für
eine Wärmepumpe und häufig ist es halt
die am 30 Jahre Laufzeit das heißt die
die nach der Wende kurz nach der Wende
eine neue Heizung gekauft haben sind
jetzt dran also die Verunsicherung im
Land riesengroß und ich glaube das muss
man ernst nehmen und wenn man als
Regierung gut beraten ist tut man das
und was ja und das finde ich ist wenn
man so will ein kollektivversagen aller
Beteiligten drei beteiligten
Regierungsparteien dieses Gesetz also es
ist ein riesen Ding und wenn man sagt
man muss CO2 einsparen und klimaneutral
bis 2045 und der Wärmesektor ist einer
wo noch wahnsinnig viel Luft nach oben
ist so dann muss man doch irgendwie das
ganze so ein Stielen dass diese
Verunsicherung möglichst nicht besteht
dass es sozial abgefedert wird dass das
mit einer Stimme kommuniziert wird und
da würde ich sagen fängt es an ehrlich
gesagt bei Robert Habeck der das
irgendwie den Gesetzentwurf
herausgegeben hat als er offenkundlich
noch nicht fertig war das hat er selber
gesagt wo übrigens und das ist ein
riesen Problem für die Grünen meinen
Augen die seit Jahren dafür kämpfen von
dieser sozialen Kälte von diesen Image
sozial kalt zu sein wegzukommen
haben wirklich Parteitage zum Thema
soziales und so weiter gemacht und
wollen nicht die Partei der besser
verdienenden sein und machen dann bei so
einem Gesetz vergessen sie als ersten
Schritt mal die soziale Frage dann
kursiert das Gesetz und Robert habe
gesagt in den Tagesthemen sozusagen Gott
oh Gott diese durchstecherei das ist so
schrecklich sozusagen schuld sind die
hat ja die FDP nicht wörtlich benannt
aber sagen war klar die FDP soll es
rausgegeben haben im politischen Berlin
wird sozusagen alles und jedes
durchgestochen und das war überhaupt
keine solide Erklärung und so und
irgendwie man kann es jetzt noch so
weiterführen im Grunde dieses wirklich
heikle Thema ist von allen Beteiligten
und dazu meine ich auch die
Protokollerklärung im Kabinett von wegen
wir sind uns einig aber irgendwie doch
nicht einig ein 30 stündiger
Koalitionsausschuss von wegen wir haben
das zwar letztes Jahr alles schon mal
verhandelt aber jetzt sind wir uns doch
total über Kreuz bis hin zu im Bundestag
wird das alles noch mal ganz anders
gemacht das führt dazu dass die Leute
die im vor Augen haben 20-24 das ist
nicht mehr lange hin einfach Angst ja
das ist das ist das Problem und deswegen
interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt nicht im Detail wer da jetzt
recht hat ja sondern ich finde in dem
Punkt in einem wahnsinnig wichtig die
Details sind auch wichtig aber
sehr wichtig ist in dem Zusammenhang ich
wollte nur sagen dass das ist total
destruktiv und und nährt wir haben
vorhin über BÜRGER IN WUT im
übertragenen Sinne gesprochen damit
nährt es genau das und wenn man das und
das ist das was ich was ich okay
Konsequenz überein das Problem ist nur
es gab noch kein Gesetz kein
Gesetzentwurf der eine so kurze
Verbindung ermöglicht hat
also wir setzen zugeschickt um
Stellungnahme
gesagt die bösen Verbände haben es
zuerst oder die bösen Gründen gegeben
was aber ganz normaler Teil ja der
Gesetzgeber Gesetzgebungsverfahren die
betroffen sind
keine Verbände Anhörung wo die Leute nur
sechs Stunden Zeit haben sich Seiten
machen also der zeitliche Druck der da
entstanden das hat dazu geführt dass
viele uns erklärt haben vorher also ihre
Regierung macht eine Verbände Anhörung
wir werden im Deutschen Bundestag mit
Sicherheit auch im Ausschuss eine
Anhörung machen weil er nicht allein
gehört worden sind und die Abgeordneten
sich einen eigenen Eindruck verschaffen
müssen aber der Druck der dahin erzeugt
wurde steht in keinem Verhältnis zu der
Notwendigkeit
ganz kurz sie haben mit diesem Druck
nichts zu tun nein wenn das sie als FDP
als Teil dieser Regierung die mit dieser
Geschwindigkeit deutschen
was vortragen
gerade gesagt sie wissen nicht so mehr
so ganz genau was in diesem
Koalitionsvertrag drin steht ich lese es
ihn mal vor uns das mal angesehen ist
sehr interessant am 24 November 2021
schreiben Sie also sie auch mit die FDP
in den Koalitionsvertrag zum ersten
Januar 25 ja soll jede neu eingebaute
Heizung auf der Basis von
65% erneuerbaren Energien betrieben
werden ja und
das ist ihnen gerade nicht eingefallen
die 65 Prozent nein nein ist wichtig
noch einmal
die 65% heißt noch Bio Methan
beispielsweise ja ganz ganz kurz ich
will nur sagen so oder Wasserstoff 23
März also 23 März 2022 wenige Monate
später 22 gibt es ein
Koalitionsausschuss da steht dann
folgendes drin auch von ihnen mit
unterschrieben wir werden jetzt
gesetzlich festschreiben dass ab dem 1
Januar 24 möglichst jede neu eingebaute
Heizung zu
65%, mit der erneuerbaren Energien
betrieben werden soll
und am 28 März 23 noch mal ein Jahr
später jetzt gerade im
Koalitionsausschuss am 24 März 22 haben
wir beschlossen gesetzlich fest zu
schreiben dass ab dem 1 Januar 24
möglichst jede neu eingebaute Heizung zu
65 % mit der erneuerbaren Energien
betrieben werden soll was ich sagen will
ist man kann dieses Gesetz doof finden
man kann das Thema Wärmepumpen doof
finden man kann diese Geschwindigkeit
doof finden das kann man alles machen
aber so zu tun als wäre das
ausschließlich auf dem Mist von Robert
Habeck unseren Leuten gewachsen nein ich
habe das ist einfach nicht in Ordnung
das waren sie alle gemeinsam ich habe
doch vorhin erklärt der Eindruck da
gibt's den Satan mit der Wärmepumpe
Robert Habeck und wir retten euch jetzt
vor diesen bösen Dämon mit der
Wärmepumpe das ist der Eindruck entsteht
ich habe vorhin vorhin erklärt sie
können das ja Leute können das sehen
dass wir ein Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben das ab 1.1.2025 der
Wärmesektor CO2 neutraler klimaneutral
mit wärmeversorgt werden soll und dabei
bleibt es auch da steht nicht drin dass
wir eine Wärmepumpe einbauen sollen da
steht 65 %. ja aber die Wärme die
Wärmepumpe bietet keine 65 %
regenerativen Energien ist voll der
Quatsch momentan
durcheinander gerade das Gefühl
entstanden da ist einer der kommt zu
euch in den Heizungskeller und dann
guckt er nach was ihr da habt und wenn
ihr nicht brav seid dann zieht euch die
Ohren lang oder klaut durch die Heizung
Frau erklären
alle gemeinsam beschlossen wir haben den
Gesetzentwurf nicht beschlossen wir
haben das Prinzip beschlossen das sind
unter großer Unterschied okay das fein
sozusagen was in der Montage gemacht
werden muss stimmt momentan nicht
okay das heißt sie haben nichts damit zu
tun
was da im Hintergrund aus ihrer Sicht
wirklich läuft ich glaube dass was im
Moment und da kann ich der der Kollege
nur zustimmt tatsächlich passiert ist
dass wir eine Situation haben in der wir
erkennen dass mit der Klimakrise hat
irgendwie was mit uns zu tun und es hat
blöderweise nicht noch was mit den
auspuffabgasen zu tun sondern eben auch
mit dem was aus der Heizung rauskommt
das ist vielen Leuten aber nicht klar
gewesen es haben aber im
Koalitionsvertrag die Grünen durchaus
das schon als Thema gehabt und die
anderen beiden Koalitionspartner die SPD
und die FDP haben dem zum Teil
zugestimmt die haben gesagt ja das mit
der Klimakrise ist schon echt ein
Problem und wir müssen was machen und
jetzt machen die Grünen was und ich
würde auch zustimmen die ganze Art und
Weise wie das Gesetz entstanden und
kommuniziert wird ist nun wirklich nicht
toll vor allem dieser soziale Aspekt der
fehlt ist ein riesen im Hintergrund gibt
es dann dass es mich so sagen ein
Phantomschmerzen derer die bis dahin mit
dem was da an Thermen verbaut wurde und
so weiter sehr gutes Geschäft ich würde
sagen das sind von Kopfschmerzen sind
richtig ökonomische Einbußen die da
passieren wir sind das letzte eins der
Länder in Europa die am meisten von der
Gasindustrie abhängig sind immer noch
und es ist ein großes Geschäft was da
was da ist und jede Industrie die ein
großes Geschäft macht hat natürlich ein
Interesse das möglichst lange weiter zu
verfolgen einfach weil sie Geld damit
verdienen das ist auch nicht verwerflich
das ist in einer Marktwirtschaft das war
so das Problem beginnt dort wo dieses
Geschäft dann tatsächlich nicht nur den
klimaschadet sondern auch dem Umbau
eines Landes hin in eine klimaneutrale
Wirtschaft und Energie meiner neutrales
heizen und was wir im Moment erleben ist
das eben suggeriert wird naja ein
bisschen wie beim Verbrenner wo wir auch
gesagt haben es Verbrenner aus na ja das
muss dann doch nicht kommen wir können
irgendwann mit efuels fahren wird jetzt
suggeriert wir brauchen eigentlich aus
der Gasheizung nicht aussteigen weil
irgendwann sie werden es wahrscheinlich
gleich auch sagen kommt dann der schöne
Wasserstoff und geht in die Netze rein
dass der nicht verfügbar ist dass der
wahnsinnig teuer ist nach wie vor ähm
das ist wahrscheinlich völlig verkehrt
es sich jetzt eine wasserstoffheizung
einzubauen weil irgendwann die Netze
möglicherweise dann eben dann den
Wasserstoff doch nicht haben das wird
nicht erzählt und dass die heizpumpe
absehbar wir können das ja in anderen
Ländern sehen Sie schon haben die
günstigste Form des Heizens sein wird es
wird eben auch nicht erzählt das heißt
hinter dieser ganzen Folie er habe halt
ein blödes Gesetz gemacht und sozial ist
er außer dem nicht ist natürlich
massives ökonomisches Interesse das
Geschäftsmodell mit dem man jetzt noch
Geld verdient weiter zu behalten und das
ist das Problem
es tut mir für den deutschen sonst mal
wirklich leid weil Deutschland
die Zeit auf die Zeit insgesamt zu
machen sie auch nicht die ganze Zeitung
dafür verantwortlich sagen Sie mir dafür
verantwortlich weil Deutschland
selbstverständlich nicht nur
Klimaschutzziele einzuhalten 2045 ein
Pfad beschritten werden
minister-gesetz
der Verkehrssektor erhält seine Ziele
nicht ein wir bauen jetzt äh jedes Jahr
1000 neue Windräder auf das bedeutet wir
haben 20.000 zusätzliche
schwerlastverkehre wenn Volker wissen
die Klimaschutzziele anhalten wollte
müsste einfach nur erklären ich verbiete
jetzt Lkw-Verkehr für drei Tage in einer
Woche mal gucken was in Deutschland
passiert
seine Ziele ein aber es hilft nicht
weiter deshalb können Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben von diesen starken
Sektor ziehen abzugehen dass das
generell über den ganzen über das ganze
Jahr zu machen weil wir verpflichtet
sind das auch einhalten wollen jedes
Jahr den die CO2 Emission in Deutschland
zu reduzieren das wird auch tatsächlich
passieren 26 27 weil der Emissionshandel
der europaweit gilt auch fürs
gebäudeverkehr umgesetzt wird das heißt
der Deckel wird von da ab immer kleiner
weshalb wir auch über andere Dinge
vielleicht überreden sollten ich habe
sehr viel Verständnis dafür dass jetzt
framing auftaucht wer dieses
Klimaschutzgesetz oder von von von den
Grünen die toll findet der will die
fossilen Energieträger weiterhin am
Laufen halten der will irgendeine
Wirtschaft dienen das ist intellektuell
irgendwie
sagen Sie mir mal ganz konkret wie
wollen sie die Klimaziele im wärmesekt
sagen sie nicht irgendwann 20 30 mit
Wasserstoff
der auch quasi 30 mit Wasserstoff wenn
wir bei mir momentan 50 neue
gaspreiswerke bauen als Staat oder bauen
lassen müssen als Staat für die
Versorgungssicherheit die auch nur mit
Erdgas betrieben würden die dürfen nur
gebaut werden weil hat weil Wasserstoff
ready die spannende Frage ist warum wir
das Veröffentlichen Bereich und bei den
Privaten nicht warum erlauben wir weil
das Zeug noch nicht da ist ja gut dann
erlauben sie weiterhin wir haben
Bioethanol Biomethan Biodiesel für 6
Millionen Haushalte könnten wir die
versorgen sicherstellen wir haben Holz
beispielsweise warum heute am Schreiner
für verboten werden soll dann seine
Abfälle in seiner ein Heizung zu packen
Leute mir nicht ganz ein anderen auch
nicht es gibt andere Möglichkeiten auch
und wenn sie sagen wasserstoff ist noch
so teuer stimmt aber in dem Moment die
man größerer Wagner steht gibt's andere
Anbieter da gibt's nicht nur LG aus den
Vereinigten sondern Wasserstoff aus
Australien Neuseeland definitiv ich war
da keiner sagen die bauen gerade in
Neuseeland Geothermiekraftwerke wo sie
Strom erzeugen für 0,1 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde da können Sie das Ding
rausholen zur Wasserstofftankstelle der
Welt werden und wenn sie sagen dass eine
ein Check auf die Zukunft auch das was
Robert halk mit dem Kopf hat dass wir 20
30 so viel so viel Wind und Sonne haben
dass wir 80 Prozent damit den können ist
auch auf die Zukunft was sie tun ist für
mich so ein bisschen Klimapolitik ihre
Lösungen sind immer entweder ganz weit
in der Zukunft oder sie heißen
Emissionshandel und beim Emissionshandel
ist immer dann wenn der kommt und härter
wird sind sie die Partei die sagen oh
jetzt sind die Preise uns zu Hause bei
dem Benzinpreis im letzten Jahr passiert
als sie dafür gesorgt haben dass die
Autofahrer entlastet wurden als die
lassen sich besonders
sehr propagiert sagen sie würden sie mir
jetzt sagen sie waren damals dagegen
bestimmt nicht aber lassen Sie mich noch
einen Schritt weiter gehen ich sehe sie
lächeln das zweite ist der
Emissionshandel ihre Kollegen im
Europäischen Parlament waren immer dafür
dass der Emissionshandel nicht
verschärft wird und die nehmen
Augenblick in dem der emissionshall im
letzten Jahr einmal schon automatisch
erhöht werden sollen weil die FDP dafür
nicht zu erhöhen das heißt
Emissionshandel ist dann immer diese
Lösung und irgendwann kommt
also die die Aussetzung des co2-preises
waren Beschluss der Ampel auch Bitten
der Sozialdemokraten das kann man also
können sie vielleicht bei sich noch mal
nachlesen und der Emission handelt
funktioniert der funktioniert im
Energiebereich er funktioniert im
Wirtschaftsbereich der funktioniert
definitiv auch und wird funktionieren
Verkehrsbereich und im Wärme im
Gebäudebereich aber wenn das so ist dann
müssten sie doch allen Leuten sagen geht
so schnell wie möglich aus euren
Gasheizung raus weil das so teuer ja
aber das wird langsam teure jetzt wenn
sie jetzt in die Wärmepumpe gehen müssen
was ist auf einmal was unter anderem
jetzt haben die Leute Zeit sich darauf
einzustellen und damit umzugehen
Kuchen haben wollen und gleichzeitig
essen wollen
er hilft mir jetzt nicht weiter also
entscheidend
Energiegesetz kommt oder wird die FDP
sagen nein es kommt aber es kommt nicht
so wie wir kein Gesetz so aus dem
Bundestag heraus relativ offensichtlich
anders werden